let's go next to the 908 area code
caller from 908 what's your name where
are you calling from
yeah that's you hi I'm Brian from New
Jersey
hey Brian and so I just I just had a
question about um so just a puppet I
just turned 18 and I just wanted to know
where should I go and to give you a
context I said I'm from Jersey I'm going
to college in Missouri so obviously like
two opposite sides of the spectrum but
full spectrum and so which would be like
to know the most beneficial places those
had a candidate or a question strategic
so conceivably you could vote at like
the address you grew up in in New Jersey
or you could register to vote where
you're going to college in Missouri is
that my understanding your question
correctly yeah I almost think it comes
down to what local races you might be
able to vote in so if because up for the
presidency in all likelihood New
Jersey's gonna go to the Democrat in
Missouri is going to go to the
Republican for president I would say
vote in Missouri because it's I think
it's more likely Missouri goes blue than
New Jersey goes red that's strictly
presidential but a better way to think
about it might actually be is there a
member of Congress where is there a
congressional race that has the
potential to make a bigger impact like
is there a red district in Missouri that
might be able to flip blue or conversely
is there a blue district in New Jersey
that risks going red which we would want
to prevent and I would probably decide
based on that more than the presidential
election okay cool okay thank you for
that okay one quick question yeah okay
okay so it and what ways do you think I
could you know get politically involved
at my college other than you know just
like running for like a student Senate
to see that type of thing well yeah I
mean student government would be great
get out the vote would be great I think
get out the vote is huge potential
because if you you know on getting
people on campus to register to vote
it's a population that is much less
likely to vote than older people you can
really have an impact
particularly at local races so other
than student government I would get
involved and get out the vote campaigns
get get people registered yeah my goal
okay thank you so much appreciate it all
right really appreciate the call thank
you so much okay I'm out of time for
calls sorry to everybody who's holding
and everybody I didn't get to but I will
take calls again and really appreciate
everybody who called in today